firstly right angle triangles find that
angle over there in the corner what do
you think it goes working we think this
red red one he di ba do you think it's
amazing that's a good to know oh my what
this event is also a awesome job I can't
do what he's done is he's identified
inside okay to hold on each fall they
would meet under christy I know it's
warm I'm 12 but um this is this is the
point where you want to nail the landing
rather than get more confused be unsure
and believe me like we just started
looking at this halfway because the area
business right it is starting to get
trickier he's really really need to make
sure we're on the same page so just to
rehearse what Kerry is done and if I
like it if he's identified on the
diagram in relation to his angle there
it is adjacent I thought you because
these the vibration I'll add one more
thing to that defines not working and
I'm call it has to relate to an angle
yessir cousin to something else it's a
level 17 so that's why he are probably
what you wanted was actually to have
that swing one of their deli we don't
actually have to write that often
electrical until you go straight from
this line are maybe this one and then
you start around from there so i'll be
happy with this aim
he's never catch a man why we rounded it
in this case you've got the EGR and
their whole numbers there's no reason to
expect we have a really insane level of
detail via spiga probably approximation
so it's not uncommon to contain it but
besides it's like that's not really the
point of the question 50 degrees is
putting on personally now we'll come
back to mom be troublesome this in a
second we will all do it but let's see
do we get agreement on twelve point
seven minutes yeah okay we're dressing
regular slice off a check is it a
reasonable oncol I'm happy with that you
could rounded up to 13 but the question
didn't specify I'm pretty happy with it
okay now here's where it gets
interesting is this for the sake of time
I do all my anniversary today we could
walk through I have no doubt that people
have gone each of you got me to be
honest and done them by a correct method
and depending on context you can all get
warm up let me quickly walk in here
without writing it how you could get ice
on them this is what kind of try to
suspend friend right angle which means
if you wanted to you could find this
length over here right using some nice
address and then you can pay him these
kinds of perpendicular so thankfully
then that's going to be the
perpendicular height so then off you go
base plan pipe onto that would work
alternatively last lesson we looked at
area of triangle even when it's not the
right angle triangle and in fact even
without this size
so long as you thought the able to Gary
Gary 254 is another way to go down area
what is it yes off time baby kindly geez
and a and B true length that's around
the table if you call this C and half a
be buying duty degree will be perfect ok
now if you did that dude pins up who did
that yep okay and you guys they wanted
to go up what was that 70 which one to
get one I am the anything I have any one
race is very mu advocate now the
differences are going to come and seems
like say the difference between this
life and this life okay now the
difference is mine you so much its
consumer the difference is very small
but that's where it creeps in because a
little bit of an angle adds like a few
decimal points off a little bit but you
roll down the correct procedure and I'm
quite happy